en même temps que le spectacle démarre
on vous donnera une feuille de route où
il y aura tout le plan des déplacements
de tout le spectacle
abandonnez vous allez entendre pas
d'aller à dame enfin il avoue sorti le
drapeau ça dure cinq fois la bêtise là
et là vous dansez puisqu'on est dans les
musiques d'après guerre dont glenn
miller par balle à un bras d'après
certains l'avouent dans ces deux par
deux et vous mettez le drapeau sous le
bras
c'est très bien comme ça pas plus que ça
ouais c'est bientôt car rené l'espace
pour l'espace question date en concert
oui c'est bien là c'est bien
attention
vous décidez ça fait deux heures
d'antenne
non
c'est très bien je vois pas simple super
ça c'est fait pour faire des publicités
c'est les années 50
donc voilà c'est lustucru c'est liszt et
alsace et mon savon c'est c'est c
qui et voilà et on va faire tout
cas un jeu scénographique avec ses
cartons et les images projetées qui vont
nous rappeler les années 50 étaient les
publicités jean mineur ou jetons